-You know, it's difficult to
keep up with the number
of Trump aides and officials who
have been fired or forced out.
Many have moved on,
several are under indictment,
and some of those
we think have left
haven't really gone anywhere
at all.
For a look at where they are,
it's time for "The Check In."
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
Throughout the campaign,
President Trump constantly
bragged about knowing
the best people, and then
promised to hire those people
once he got
into the White House.
-I know the best people.
I know the best managers.
I know the best dealmakers.
I know people
that will make us so strong.
I know guys that are so good.
I put people in
that have great ability.
But the cabinet, we're gonna
have all the best people.
We got the smartest -- I know
the smartest, I know the best.
I know the best negotiators.
I know the ones
that are overrated.
you never heard of
that are better
than all of them.
But we're gonna use
our best people.
-You know what I don't think
you use? The best thesaurus.
[ Laughter ]
You use "best" so much,
you're basically
President Kenny Bania.
-I told you Mendy's
had the best pea soup.
The best, Jerry. The best.
[ Laughter ]
-And when Trump wasn't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And when Trump wasn't bragging
about how his people
were the best, he was bragging
about how awful they were.
-I'm going to get these great
business leaders.
I will get these
great business leaders.
These great, great people.
And I have to say some of them
are not nice people.
Do you agree? Who cares? Right?
Who cares?
Some of them you don't want
to have dinner with.
They are vicious, brutal,
horrible human beings.
Who cares? Who the hell cares?
Some are nice,
but some are terrible people.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Really covering your bases
there.
[ Imitating Trump ]
"These people are the best
"and also the worst. We got
geniuses, business giants,
also we got some murderers."
[ Laughter ]
"We got people who take their
shoes off on airplanes.
It's a mixed bag."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] But I have to
give Trump credit here,
because he did warn us
that he was going to hire
some vicious, horrible people,
and he followed through.
And then, as expected, some of
those awful people got fired
for their awfulness, but they
didn't exactly go away.
Take former Navy SEAL
and surrogate
for the Trump campaign,
Carl Higbie.
Higbie was appointed to be
the face of an agency called
the Corporation for National
& Community Service.
His job was to...
Basically, he was doing PR
for people who help people.
Super easy job. But less than
six months into that job,
he had to resign
after CNN uncovered
racist and homophobic comments
Higbie had made
several years ago.
Now where did he make
these comments?
Did he make them in a whispered
conversation in a crowded bar?
A message board
full of fellow racists?
No, he made them fully
on the radio.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, not sure that's
the best way to jack up
your book sales.
[ Laughter ]
"Gays, Muslims, Mexicans,
"and Rhode Island
can go to hell.
Everyone else,
check out my new book!"
[ Laughter ]
And while you're at it,
pick up Carl's other books,
"Chicken Soup for the Soulless"
and "Fifty Shades of Cray."
[ Laughter ]
Also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know you're insane when you
go after Rhode Island.
[ Laughter ]
"Rhode Island's been pulling the
wool over our eyes for too long.
Face it, you're just
Connecticut's foreskin!"
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
So after those comments
came out,
Higbie was fired from his job.
So that's the end for him,
right?
You can't come back from that.
Well, not exactly.
-A former Navy SEAL and Trump
administration staffer who
resigned after racist, sexist,
homophobic remarks
that he had made on the radio
were exposed
has now been hired
by a pro-Trump group --
a pro-Trump group whose leaders
Trump had dinner with
just last week.
-He was fired and then promptly
hired by the political Super PAC
that's working
with the President
which sends a message
about what they view as
tolerable and not tolerable.
-So Higbie did something
terrible,
but instead of getting rid
of him,
they just moved him
to a new job.
To put it in Catholic terms, he
got moved to another diocese.
[ Laughter ]
"This is Father Pat.
He just moved here
from Boston, Akron, and Omaha."
"Kids, get in the car."
[ Laughter ]
And not only was Higbie hired
by a pro-Trump group,
but he's still also still...
So the guy who repeatedly said
racist things about black people
is still on the board of a group
run by the National Diversity
Coalition.
That's like Charlie Sheen
teaching D.A.R.E.
[ Laughter ]
"So remember, kids,
if someone offers you drugs,
you point them my way."
[ Laughter ]
So despite all
of his horrible remarks,
Higbie is still working
for Trump,
and he's not the only one.
Just a few months
after Higbie resigned,
Trump's personal aide,
28-year-old John McEntee,
was abruptly forced out as well.
-A personal aide
to President Trump escorted out
of the White House
under a cloud of controversy.
-Johnny McEntee,
President Trump's personal
assistant, his body man,
abruptly forced out of his post
and escorted off
the White House grounds Monday.
NBC News confirming McEntee
is under investigation
by the Secret Service for
serious financial crimes.
McEntee's departure strips
the President of another
of his closest
and longest serving aides.
-Side note, buddy,
if that's your office,
you don't need to put on a tie.
[ Laughter ]
That's like driving
the bulldozer at a landfill
in a top hat and tails.
[ Laughter ]
Now an investigation found
that McEntee's gambling habits
had posed a security risk,
but thanks to President Trump,
he was able to bounce back
almost immediately.
-Johnny McEntee's very much
remaining
in the President's orbit because
just minutes after this news
broke of his departure,
the Trump campaign announced
that they had hired him
to work as senior adviser
for those re-election efforts
in 2020.
-So he got escorted off
the White House grounds
and into a promotion.
That's like getting thrown out
of a bar and the bouncer saying,
"Get out and stay out
and come back tomorrow,
'cause you're the manager now!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump keeps recycling
these people and others
because he only uses one
yardstick to measure employees.
"Are they loyal to me?"
And the problem with that is
that the kinds of people who
are unquestionably loyal
to an ignorant bigot like Trump
are pretty much
always terrible people.
There's no pool of thoughtful
and qualified candidates for him
to draw from, because you can't
be thoughtful and qualified
and also loyal to a President
who is neither.
So despite having been fired
or having shamefully resigned
because of racist comments
or straight up crimes,
none of these people have really
suffered the consequences
you and I probably would have
had we made similar mistakes
at such a high profile job,
or any job for that matter.
If you have an interview
at Chipotle and they say,
"Why do you want to work here?"
And you say, "well, I got fired
from Taco Bell for screaming
the 'N'-word,"
they will not hire you.
[ Laughter ]
But I know someone who might.
[ Audience groans ]
This has been "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]